[Music]
it's the most wonderful i've always
loved christmas but as a mom it's a lot
of work in between the wrapping the
shopping the cooking the decorating
sweetie we don't drink the tree water
because we're people right oh god
there's almost no time to actually enjoy
it and only one thing oh no what is it
could make it even more stressful my
mother's coming for christmas oh my
[ __ ] god
mom hi mom
mom i'm the actual [ __ ] i'm here to see
my daughter on easter it's christmas
christmas i cannot wait to spend every
waking minute with you oh
no
where's your tree i guess you could've
been a little busy well clearly not at
the gym look i'm a 34 year old woman and
she's still telling me how to live my
life my mom got her hair kind of colored
exactly like mine is that normal we
don't like to use the word normal you
are going to be my best friend forever
yeah
i want to throw a christmas party where
my house yes and 184 people are coming
how much does this cost can you put a
price tag on
actually just wanted to enjoy christmas
this year you are a mom moms don't enjoy
they give joy she's gonna keep treating
you like this until you fight her
physically i don't want you to meet my
mom
now watch me christmas is supposed to be
fun
say christmas back
perfect decorations no more perfect
anything let's put the ass back in
christmas that didn't come out exactly
as i planned it but you guys get one and
we know what you're asking
my daughter thinks that i'm so hard on
her i had a horrible mother she once
slapped me for wearing open-toed shoes
on a sailboat there was a different time
then it was two months ago
for all day and all night i'm kind of on
a first date with santa number two how's
you guys meet oh waxman's balls slight
sting on your nutsack
i don't think i've ever felt this way
about another human being in my entire
life i can pull my butt crack open for
you if you want no one's ever asked if
they could hold their butt crack open
for me before i'll hold my butt crack
open for you anytime you want carlo that
is so romantic
every time i think i'm the [ __ ] up one
in this group you open your mouth we
went to prom together oh boy and then
i'm like i'm doing great
[Music]